bienvenidos ahora vamos a hacer otro
problema de tensión y este es
ligeramente más difícil que el anterior
ya que tenemos que usar álgebra un poco
más sofisticada pero en realidad no es
tan difícil deben aprender a resolver
estos problemas porque son típicos en
los exámenes vamos a calcular la tensión
en estos cables bueno sabemos que en
este
punto no hay ningún movimiento está
quieto no hay movimiento ni a la
izquierda ni a la derecha ni arriba ni
abajo por lo que sabemos que bueno en
esta cuerda su tensión es muy muy fácil
la fuerza de tensión de esta cuerda es
la misma del peso que está sosteniendo
en este caso son de 10 New Solo que la
tensión de esta cuerda es hacia arriba
ya que el peso de esta de este objeto
está siendo jalado hacia abajo por la
gravedad Bueno entonces ahora vamos a
calcular la tensión en estos dos cables
t1 y
t2 bueno de lo de nueva cuenta en este
punto donde se unen ambos cables la
tensión Perdón la fuerza o no hay
velocidad aquí la suma de las fuerzas
netas en este punto la suma de estas
fuerzas debe ser igual a cer0 ya que no
hay ningún tipo de movimiento ni
velocidad ni
aceleración Entonces vamos a dibujar los
vectores primero vamos a analizar los
componentes horizontales en esta sección
vamos a descomponer cada vector de estas
cuerdas de tensión en sus
componentes
horizontales en este caso este va a ser
más o menos aquí este este vector le
vamos a llamar t1
x y eh el ángulo si Aquí bueno por la
propiedad del eh líneas paralelas y
ángulos internos el ángulo en esta parte
va a ser el mismo que el ángulo en esta
sección Así que aquí también tenemos 30
gr Y de igual manera en nuestra cuerda
T2 su vector va a ser este es un poco
más
chiquito le vamos a llamar
de2 subíndice x y su ángulo aquí va a
ser igual a 60 gr y bueno ahora eh
ustedes ya deben estar más que
familiarizados con el uso de las
funciones trigonométricas para calcular
estos vectores para calcular nuestro
vector en t1 de X vamos a usar la
función coseno ya que es la que
involucra el cateto adyacente y la
hipotenusa Entonces tenemos que el
coseno de 30 gr va a ser igual a t1 de X
ent
t1 de manera similar tenemos tenemos que
este el componente en
T2 va a ser ahora Bueno también va a ser
el coseno nada más que este caso es el
coseno de 60 gr va a ser igual a
t2x ent T2 si tienen alguna duda con
respecto a este uso de las funciones
trigonométricas Les recomiendo que
repasen los videos que hay explicando
este tipo de funciones para que se les
sea más fácil comprender esto
bueno qué más sabemos de estos vectores
Bueno vamos de hecho vamos a despejar me
interesa saber la componente horizontal
entonces voy a despejar t1 dex t1 de X
es igual
a t1 por el coseno de 30 gr Y a lo mismo
hago con T2 de X que va a ser igual a T2
por el coseno de 60 gr si recuerdan sus
triángulos de 30 60 y 90 gr el coseno de
30 gr va a ser igual a raíz
3 ent 2 y el coseno de 60 gr va a ser
igual a 1/2 Entonces nos queda t1 de X
igual
a
ra3
2 por
t1 y el componente en x de T2 va a ser
igual a 1 medio por T2 y lo que sabemos
es que ambos vectores ambas
componentes van a ser iguales ya que una
está jalando a la derecha otra está
jalando a la izquierda Pero el punto en
donde están unidas no se mueve entonces
tienen que ser iguales Así
que tengo que
ra3 2 t1 es igual
a 1/2 de T2 y esto lo puedo
simplificar dejándolo
ra3 / 2 * t1 - 1/2 de T2 esto igual a 0
Y es más vamos a simplificarlo un poco
más vamos a multiplicar todo por 2 para
eliminar estos elementos entonces me
queda ra3 por t1 - 1 2 2 queda 1 - T2 =
0 * 2 queda 0 y vamos a reservar esta
función tenemos una función y dos
incógnitas en este punto no nos sirve
mucho Pero más adelante tengo el
presentimiento de que nos va a ser
útil Okay entonces qué va a pasar con
los componentes verticales los
componentes en y bueno en este caso
tengo mi componente de
t1 vertical Ay Dios t1 sub índice y es
este y mi
componente
vertical va a ser este en
T2
t2x bueno Qué sabemos de estos dos
componentes sabemos que la suma de ambas
componentes verticales va a ser igual a
esta fuerza que está jalando hacia abajo
hacia 10 newt entonces bueno primero de
igual manera que encontramos los
componentes horizontales vamos a
encontrar estos componentes
verticales
y vamos a ver cómo podemos encontrar su
valor tenemos que t1 ahora lo voy a
poner con este color
eh la la función trigonométrica que nos
sirve en este caso es la función seno ya
que es el cateto opuesto tenemos
entonces que el seno de 30
gr va a ser igual a componente de 1 en y
entre t1 que es la hipotenusa Y tenemos
de igual manera el seno de 60 gr que es
T2 es igual al componente 2 en y entre
t1 que es la
hipotenusa y de la misma manera Bueno
vamos a despejar
T2 x y t1 perdón t1 y y T2 Y entonces
nos queda que t1 en y es ig a t1 por el
seno de 30 gr
t2y es = a T2 por el seno de 60 gr
simplificando el seno de 30 gr es igual
a
1/2 el seno de 60 gr es igual a ra3 / 2
y nos queda entonces t1 de y es = a 1/2
de
t1 y
T2 y es = a
ra3 ent 2
T2 y lo que sabemos Es que la suma de
ambos es igual a 10 n Entonces vamos a
poner t1 de y viene siendo
1/2 de
t1 + t2y que viene siendo
√3 entre 2 de T2 esta suma es igual a 10
New vamos a despejar un poco Aquí vamos
a multiplicar todo por dos y nos va a
quedar
t1 + ra3
T2 = 2 * 10 20 New y aquí ya tenemos
otra fórmula que podemos usar de la
misma manera que tenemos dos fórmulas
con dos interrogantes vamos a dejar Más
o menos el mismo formato que tenemos
esta ahora vamos a multiplicar todo por
raíz de 3 y me quedan
√3 * t1 + 3
de 2 raí 3 * ra3 es = a
3 es igual a
ra3 por
20 bueno Entonces ahora sí tengo estas
dos fórmulas y ahora lo que voy a hacer
puedo hacerlo de varias formas Pero lo
que voy a hacer es
restar esta fórmula menos esta fórmula y
esta operación la voy a hacer aquí
entonces raí de 3 t1 - √3 t1 queda igual
a 0 entonces
tengo 3
T2 lo voy a escribir aquí -
T2 - 3
T2 es igual
a 0
-3 *
20 - T2 - 32 me queda igual a -4 T2 es
igual a -
√3 * 20 paso esto de estar aquí lo voy a
pasar dividiendo en esta sección y me va
a quedar que T2 es igual a 20 / 4
√3 newtons y esta es mi magnitud en la
cuerda número dos aquí ya encontré esta
esta
magnitud es 5 bueno la pongo aquí
T2 es igual a 5 * ra 3
New y ahora que tengo este valor voy a
sustituirlo en esta otra fórmula y lo
voy a poner en este color
verdecito tengo raíz de 3 t1 - T2 que T2
es 5
ra3 Y esto es igual a 0
Entonces ra3 por t1 es ig a 5 *
ra3 y esto lo paso dividiendo en este
lado de la ecuación de manera que t1 va
a ser igual a 5 ya que ra3 entre ra3 es
igual a 1 t1 es igual 5 New ya tengo el
valor de esta tensión t1 igual a 5 n
fíjense aquí que esta tensión de esta
cuerda Es mayor que la de t1 lo que es
tiene sentido Ya que este ángulo es eh
más grande y el la componente vertical
que está cargando más peso que este y
también noten que si yo sumo t1 + T2 me
da algo más que 10 n este ra3 es la
energía que se está desperdiciando por
estas componentes eh horizontales porque
las cuerdas no están jalando
directamente de arriba hacia abajo sino
tienen una componente a la derecha o a
la izquierda y esta es la fuerza que se
desperdicia en este sistema o en esta
cómo están distribuidas estas cuerdas y
hasta aquí llega este problema los veo
en el siguiente
video